est-ce que tu aimes l'argent oui c'est
quelque chose de très précieux pour moi
alors moi j'aime l'argent c'est à dire
que j'aime l'argent en petite quantité
c'est-à-dire que quand on a une petite
quantité sur soi on aime bien parce que
on est plus libre j'aime beaucoup avoir
de l'argent quand j'en veux pour faire
je sais pas moi pour rien pour aller
dans des fois et tout je m'éclate une
après midi après j'ai plus d'argent mais
c'est pas grave
si je défonce pas beaucoup je garde
surtout l'argent et sur mon compte en
banque j'ai 1000 francs
[Musique]
des grosses choses c'est à dire l'année
dernière je me suis acheté un vélo et
pour l'instant je suis en train de faire
un projet je voudrais m'acheter un
ordinateur et d'où tu viens l'argent que
tu as mis sur ce compte je garde des
enfants et je nourritais chaque quand
les gens sont partis en vacances et je
fais les marchés tous les samedis je
viendrai pas en avoir trop parce que
comme j'ai beaucoup de projets j'ai
beaucoup de rêve j'ai besoin de rêver et
si j'en avais trop ben je pourrai plus
rêver